capsules linguistiques avec guy bertrand
on le reconnaît surtout à sa voix et ses
fameux statut linguistique leurs potes
de noms français équivalent à plus de 25
ans que guy bertrand écoute corrige
conseil les journalistes les animateurs
et même les auditeurs il est devenu une
référence à l'enfance est une langue qui
est rigoureuse qui précise c'est elle a
longtemps la langue du droit
international la langue de la diplomatie
originaire de trois rivières c'est un
passionné des langues
ils parlent de leur sonorité leur
musicalité en 1976 il décide de se
porter à la défense du français
j'allais dans des magasins et ont parlé
en anglais à montréal
et là je suis dit mais mon dieu diop
il ya un décalage parce qu'à trois
rivières on parle français tout le temps
j'ai eu une espèce d'éveil je me suis
dit c'est important de protéger cette
langue et je ne le fais pas
politiquement absolument pas mais je le
fais avec mes humbles moyens l'ayatollah
de la langue qui bertrand
cet éveil lui a valu le surnom de
l'ayatollah de la langue surnom donné
par rené homier roy
mais c'est un matelas gentil c'est pas
une année à toi qui fais des fatwas
l'habitude fait des créateurs qui
essaient toujours de que les gens
s'améliore
d'où le coup on ne reçoit pas des
réprimandes mais des suggestions dit
michel suau j'ai rougi tellement proche
des états unis connaît le mot à dire sur
tout seul et lui la traduction
un gardien de la langue pour annie
desrochers il se voit plus comme un
enquêteur oui doit être à l'affût de ce
qui se dit de cette langue vivante qui
ai parlé dans notre société
et lorsqu'on se présente devant une
commission vaut-il mieux perdre son
mémoire ou perdre la mémoire
c'est quelqu'un qui peut couper la
société et pas coupé de l'époque dans
laquelle il vit il est branché sur ce
qui se dit un peu partout sur cette
langue là qui vivante
il reconnaît que la langue change on a
proposé déjeuner buffet pour remplacer
lors des six broches personne ne voulut
guy bertrand suggère assurent ils
collaborent même avec la maison du petit
robert pour l'ajout des expressions
québécoises comme se tirer une bûche qui
fait désormais partie du dictionnaire
alors quand on dit à quelqu'un tu peux
te tire une bûche même prendre chaise
viens t'asseoir avec nous
venez manger avec nous tu es la
convivialité je peux dire chaud bah si
vous voulez mais chaud elle réserve
surtout au spectacle heures rac
habituellement flexibilité ouverture
d'une vigilance devant des expressions
utilisées couramment mais qui n'ont
aucun sens selon lui celui qui m'énerve
le plus tout ce qui comporte le mot
table
la table est mise ça met la table pour
puis on met la table puis tous les
personnes mangent mais tout le monde met
la table ça ça m'agace parce que mettre
la table c'est disposer les couverts
pour manger aujourd'hui guy bertrand
fait partie des récipiendaires du prix
culturel du québec
ça me touche parce que c'est c'est un
prix qui vient du gouvernement c'est un
prix qui est c'est un prix important
il suffit de regarder les autres qui ont
remporté ce même prix je suis assez
bonne compagnie j'ai l'honneur de
remettre à monsieur guy bertrand le prix
georges-émile-lapalme 2010 est un prix
important qu'il reçoit avec le sentiment
du devoir accompli
ici elle est bonne longueur 10 radio
canada montréal
[Applaudissements]